a lot of the jobs that people took
during covid we make the assumption that
they wanted to work for us when they
took the job during covid
in the reality is some people took the
job because it was a job during covid
and in their own minds it was never
supposed to be permanent you know maybe
some of them fell in love but they're as
soon as the market opened up their
intention was always to leave so we
can't completely beat ourselves up
um if if we do lose some people
um but I think a lot of people are
um they're bouncing they're they're
trying things
um I mean let's be realistic a lot of
young people move back home so their
bills are lower so they can afford to
wait and hang out
um I think the gig economy is a real
thing and what Uber and those companies
they built into the vernaculars idea of
a gig economy and I think people really
fancy being Freelancers maybe even
freelance servers that I work for three
hotels because I want to pick up shifts
here that suit me beehive and and and
what does the gig economy mean in
traditional in traditional employment I
think that's a big part of it to be
honest
um
but I think a lot of people are are also
recognizing that money is less important
to them than than the relationships and
their experiences and I think people are
okay making less
um so they may have cut or stabilized
their incomes and they they maybe don't
have that that crazy ambition the the
thing that I fear
and we've touched upon this before which
is people are less afraid of quitting
now young people are less afraid of
quitting and they're building the gig
economy lives for themselves my fear is
that they're going to go from job to job
to job when we were younger you couldn't
quit a job in less than one year because
it would look bad on your resume right
now three months whatever goodbye
you know and my fear is Flash Forward
five years
one of two things will definitely happen
an employer will look at you that in
five years you've had nine jobs I'm not
going to hire you because I just can't
trust that you're gonna stick around
or and you've had nine jobs in five
years you haven't been around anywhere
long enough to go through a cycle of
good times and bad times and so you have
no discernible skill set
and my fear is that what feels great now
it's it's going to have consequences in
a few years
um and
um I'm worried about that and I don't
know how to communicate that in a way
that that is sticky
um you know I'm talking about eating
healthy now so you don't get diabetes in
20 years I mean you know it's it's hard
that's a hard message for people to
to statistic but I'm worried about that